So this is the first day in about a week and a half
that I've actually been home
with the intention of staying home for the entire week.
Matt and I went to Utah last weekend,
and then we had one day, and then we went up to North Carolina,
where we were donating supplies and helping with relief efforts.
So today is like a Monday reset day,
and I already. It's almost 2:00.
I have made chili. I've gone to the grocery store.
I've taught my kids their lesson.
I'm about to do another load of laundry,
and I just can't wait to.
All five members of my family are home tonight.
We're eating chilly in, like, sweatshirts.
It's still really hot here,
by the way. It's not like sweatshirt weather,
but we're gonna make it sweatshirt weather.
And we're watching Twilight and cuddling.
That's all I wanna do for the next five days.
I'm also gonna need. Oh,
I also decorated the outside of our house for Halloween today,
so I'm gonna need the weather to get on board.
I'm gonna need it to be chilly now,
because all I wanna do is, like,
hide away like a Hobbit in a hole in my house.
I'm ready to go nowhere and see no one for a very long time.